a dreadful wait for news of the loved
ones
for some the tension too much to bear
at 8 40 am an ordinary morning descended
into something Unthinkable a mess
shooting
Witnesses described how 13 year old boy
suddenly opened fire on students inside
the hallway before entering his history
classroom he showed the teacher first
then turned the weapon on his classmates
as they tried to flee killing and
wounding many
I was walking up the stairs and I could
hear a sound that I thought maybe were
kids that strong firecrackers having fun
but I could hear it more and the sound
was coming from the front of the school
I saw the security guard falling to the
ground so I quickly ran from where I was
security guard is also among the Dead
the teacher left fighting for her life
this tragedy occurred in the vladislav
ribnik primary school of the Racha
Municipality of the city of Belgrade
unfortunately eight children died and
one security guard was also killed the
injured children and one school teacher
had been hospitalized no one can bring
these children back to their parents
as parents and Emergency Services
hurried to the elementary school in the
Serbian Capital the suspect was on the
phone to the police confessing the
shooting before being arrested in the
schoolyard described as quiet and good
pupil and said to be new to the class he
was led Away by police his face covered
there is yet no known motive for an
attack that the police said was
carefully planned
this was the list of children that he
intended to kill he did it alone he made
the plan by himself the plan of entering
the school of Exeter it was found on his
desk and as he said he determined the
priority Targets this sketch looks like
a video game a horror movie
these sort of things does not happen
very often in Serbia where strict gun
laws apply but in a region wrecked by
war in the 90s a weapon isn't hard to
come by like the one used on this
occasion to shatter the Peace of a
school day
organizorich Al Jazeera Belgrade